[Música]
eu sou cantora nós não foi educada pra
falar frente das pessoas eu canto mas
aqui eu tô pensando o que eu vou falar
sobre a música e silêncio 1999 17
janeiro 5 47 da manhã eu estava na minha
casa em um jogo era todo aos faca e
terremoto venham de repente um momento
para o outro e se vai conectar com
música depois maneira de que até meu foi
a tão assustador terá fez assim cima
para baixo
todo mundo pensa que terremoto faz a
cena mas esse terremoto foi tão especial
porque é uma deliberação que você começa
a sentir antes de tremer ou antes
tivesse chacoalhada quase 20 minutos
antes eu fazia aquele nota mais grave e
eu já estava meio assim acordado
sentindo algo estranho na minha coluna e
no momento que tenha fez assim
bom eu farei eu morri porque começar a
ver coisas caindo caindo caindo minha
filha no meu lado dois anos
o outro estava baixo da televisão
deitada e eu falei nossa caiu toda em
cima da minhas filhas ea procurei marido
não estava
levantei peguei a crianças assim com
duas mãos não sei como e empurre que
quebrou a porta quebrou a parede e foi
até a entrada da casa que tem coruna
mais forte quando parei percebi que era
terremoto e eu tinha dado acima da vida
todo quebrado assim assim e não tinha
nada machucado mas nesse momento o que
aconteceu nos perdemos luz seis meses
perdemos a encanamento de água
ficamos sem água quase seis meses é
comunicação caiu a autopista quase 10
quilômetros de autopista entre as
cidades interdepartamental caíram todo
ficamos em transporte sem telefone sem
computador e esse estado o que acontece
é que há muitas pessoas ficaram feridos
inclusive estrangeiros
primeiro três dias será um choque porque
não sabia o que aconteceu televisão não
funcionava a única coisa que funcionava
a rádio ea comunicados que há dentro do
cidade passava as pessoas voluntárias
falando o que aconteceu foi isso tal
coisa terremoto foi assim magnetismo 7.2
mas ainda bem outro prêmio por favor não
fique dentro da casa porque porá através
do rádio nos percebemos que muitas casas
japonesas madeiras caíram assim e muitas
pessoas ainda estava abaixo da casa e
não só alguns amigos todos músicos
juntamos um grupo e entramos no campo
chegamos aonde que está mais afetados
que inclusive pegou fogo e queimaram
todos mas ainda estava tapado e não
podia salvar
como não tinha auto pista não tinha trem
carro já tinha gastado gasolina todo nos
todos caminhamos em cima da dre via trem
como se chama o e-tron f e caminhamos a
quilômetros quilômetros até onde que as
pessoas estava enterrados ou seja ainda
estava esperando apoio
passamos noites juntos várias noites e
todos tenhamos muito medo da noite
porque quando noite treme vêm as
curiosas cridão treva completamente
escura sabe que você vê escuros de
verdade aqui é muito difícil sente
escuro mas primeira vez sentimos que há
assim aquele escuro que não tem nos dava
medo medo coletivo terceiro dia depois
desse terremoto maior bem o outro quase
magnetismo dos 7 alcançou aquilo que
estava quase quebrado quebraram de novo
muitas pessoas ficaram feridos
não sei o que poderá exigir mos que
apoiamos a outra maneira quem que não
podia falar em inglês
muitos chineses muito sua campanha de
ana bim e tornamo e inglês holandês e
muitos que não sabia falar japonês não
recebi ajuda
então nós vamos caminhando nos fomos pra
cá minha ajudar essas pessoas de um tal
monstro dentro da escola pública e todo
mundo dormimos no chão ninguém roubava
nada a ninguém mas ninguém falava nada
também por causa do medo e não saber o
que fazer ea esse momento um amigo meu
falou vamos cantar e sobre o final da
contas somos músicos tá você trouxe
algum instrumento tenho violão tá vamos
e quando subimos um lugar um pouquinho
autuou gente nós vamos fazer música
gostaria de agradecer a vocês mas todo
mundo estava com cara sem olho grande
nós sentíamos há muito medo de que não
sabia o que acontecer e aí meu amigo
começa a tocar um canção japonês que
todo mundo conhecia
primeiro quando ele começou a tocar 34
notas muitas pessoas começaram a chorar
chorar chorar chorar chorar e depois eu
comecei a cantar e quando comecei a
cantar muitas começaram a chorar mais
ainda que são aquilo que estava
segurando que a familiares falecer 1 por
causa de certeza muito e não podia
voltar porque tinha outros queridos
familiares ainda estava juntos vivos e
não podia relaxar
através da música ou seja esse momento
eu percebi na verdade nós todos sabemos
a música tinha alguma força ou seja
freqüência tinha alguma força para
contagiar uma estado alerta o estado é
extremamente perigoso e nos povo japonês
estamos muito acostumados ou seja
repetidamente evento remonta de
funcionamento e estamos costumados não
demonstrou emoção primeira parte da essa
dodó palestra eu fiquei chocada porque
muito a palavra e capacidade que a vocês
têm para pronunciar
aquilo que está pensando e projetar e
verbalizar e comunicar com as pessoas
que na verdade eu acho que eu não tenho
tanto porque fui criado na maneira de
falar - interiorizar mais e comunicar
com outra maneira
comecei a fazer música muito mais mas
seriamente depois dessa experiência de
terremoto
andar tocando a música por aqui pra lhe
crianças que foram muito chocados e não
podia dormir mais nos repetir tocando e
cantando pra eles uma pequena força mas
nós todos descobrimos que é isso pode
ser algo a mais que a música aqui que
queremos saber fazer uma pergunta sabe o
quê que há silêncio
vocês sabem o que é que há silêncio
porque não sou a brasil todos os lugares
cidade grandes
escuto rádio televisão e o tubo
computador dentro do carro fora do carro
muita barulho eu eu digo força
é um barulho porque não me dá a opção de
sentir a paz quando escuta música então
gostaria que sente-se um pouquinho essa
é a razão de que o que eu estou falando
o poder de música está conectado com a
qualidade da silence o que tem essa
música é possível pedir para vocês
levarem todos robôs 5 segundo só brigada
é pouquinho uma pequena exercício mas
deve ser efetivo
eu sou católica e cantou ópera e vocês
vão experimentar essa sensação que eu
vivo e aí vocês vão captar mais ou menos
o que que há silêncio
o pje se cinco segundos por favor
gritem vamos juntos gritamos cinco
segundos mas inspiram profundo abrir a
custar entre costales e apoio que nós
chamamos forçamos como se fosse
carregando coisa pesado assim o dos três
e
[Aplausos]
muito obrigada
queria mostrar esse que há silêncio por
favor sentem mas eu digo de uma questão
aqui essa força que vocês sentirão agora
e você se identificaram que há silêncio
silêncio foi mostrado sucos ou como se
fosse uma matéria que a até agora tinha
barulho de repente terminou
esse foi o silêncio mas o silêncio é uma
coisa que não podemos materializar podem
materializar silêncio silêncio existe
desde sempre me parece só que hoje em
dia tanto barulho que existe esse
silêncio está sendo ignorados e na b a
tati gula que é uma grande educadora de
música não se curam 19 deixou um livro
tão maravilhoso falando sobre a nucleus
de som núcleo de som é um silêncio antes
título anuncia all antes de falar
o antes de produzir uma nota precisamos
sentir primeiro silêncio que existe
dentro da essa música ou seja com uma
nota
e você conecta com e silêncio e depois
projeto esse sonoridade diferente do
aquele por gritos o puro barulhos aquele
puro casuísmo de ritmo gptou porque
nosso escutamos esse valor do silêncio
já faz muitos anos que estamos sendo
falado há anos não sei se tenha tempo na
época da renascença em um livro que fala
sobre esse
silêncio se chama música mundana
estamos dentro dessa música que há
barulho que faz se chama música
instrumental íris e essas gritos que nós
construímos musical humana e outro
escrituras chama de música mundana que
no es conta música o nota que não escuta
frequências
então quando nós tocamos alguma música
ou alguma palavra para averbar exames
quando acompanha essa frequência extra
nós recebemos essa informação
de outra maneira mas se não está
capacitado ou seja pra nó sentia essa
capacidade dentro nós nos esquecemos que
podemos usar
estamos sendo bombardeados todos os dias
com muita palavra muitas ong's muita
música freqüência da nota de orquestra
vinte anos atrás será 440 mega hertz e
hoje em dia 443 ele significa ele está
mais agudo dentro da fibt o nat falamos
não vou falar de matemática não tenho
tempo mas dentro dessas freqüências nos
percebemos que cada vez mais freqüência
está mais agudos mas vamos perguntar a
essas frequências estão conectados com a
silêncio de cada notas que aquilo que
deixar nós tocar nosso coração você está
consumindo som ressonância com qualidade
você está andando músicas verdadeiras
para teus filhos porque se música
freqüência se e essa freqüência alimenta
nós como nó terremoto que as pessoas
começaram relaxar se poder contagiar com
essa maneira nossa humanidade
estamos escolhendo materiais melhores
para nós mesmos
o estamos ignorando ou tá tentando
manipular nosso mesmo isso que eu sempre
sinto quando voltou para a cidade porque
eu vivo na campo dentro da natureza eu
escuto silêncios mas silêncios diferente
qualidade e quando veio na cidade ter
muita informação muitas informações e
nos ignorámos por exemplo e ser a
palavra muito da nossa trás
ou seja continua sendo palavras quando
você está triste freqüência muda quando
você está feliz
se pode captar eu fico feliz se não
sinto muito mas queria usava um bo
porque bambu tem mesmo uma ressonância
do nosso corpo humano do sul então
instrumentos vende essa esse razão
também flautas de osso é pra contar a
história dessa pessoa flauta de bambu
também mesmos música está sempre com a
junto com silêncio quando música não
existe oportunidade de deixar as pessoas
sentirem o silêncio
essa música alguma coisa não está bem
mas a música que não está bem
ou nossa sensibilidade nossa também
isso é uma colecionadora cento eu também
estou buscando isso esse com essa
freqüência seja muito mais nítido haia
consciente e educação ea crenças antigas
não estaria e vida proibindo que nos
aceitamos que como nós somos talvez é
muito mais fácil de comunicar e talvez
não precisa nem de idiomas
obrigada
[Música]
[Aplausos]